what occurs to me is
i'm wondering
if this has implications for what it
means to be
alive in the colloquial sense so forget
about in the biological sense so we
think of our skin as dead and our bones
are dead and perhaps dead isn't the
right term but let's say animated
animated with life with vim with brielle
yet you've showed that somehow you can
still trigger vim and brio
not via this electrical manipulation i
thought it was that but does this have
any bearing as to what we consider to be
alive or it's a or it's a
are unrelated
um i'll tell you that one of the things
that this kind of work does is really
illustrate the
insufficiency of our vocabulary so
people often argue for example i mean
alive is a funny thing i don't i don't
actually know what alive really i don't
have a good definition the these cells
and these organisms are for sure alive
in the traditional sense i mean the
cells are alive there's no there's no
getting around that but but but people
will often argue for example are they
robots are they organisms are they uh
you know these are they machines these
kinds of things and and and
josh bongard and i wrote a paper
addressing this question basically
pointing out that
though that terminology is almost
useless now it was it was great 50 years
ago when you could
you when it was really easy to tell
apart machines that were that were that
were um boring predictable they were
they were
designed right and living things which
were surprising and interesting and and
warm and wet and um and evolved those
things are now so intermixed
that with modern with modern techniques
of a digital evolution and
bioengineering and synthetic morphology
that distinction does not exist anymore
and so it used to be that you can sort
of like you could knock on something and
if you hear a hollow metallic sound and
you say ah yeah that that came off a
factory that's a machine and i'm you
know morally um uh okay with taking it
apart and doing whatever i want with it
and if you were to do this and and it
was sort of so soft and squishy then you
would say that's evolved and it's living
and i better i better be nice to it that
right though that easy distinction is
just
that doesn't exist anymore so we need we
need a better vocabulary i mean they're
they're alive for sure but if you want
to ask questions about whether they are
machines or robots or living organisms
or that that all that stretches the
vocabulary which is no longer up to the
task